A couple of cool properties as we said,
that this does,
it's very easy to construct the MHI for
one TAL from the other.
So you can go from TAL 30 to TAL 15 and
that's basically a linear scaling,
right.
So if I have an action that can go fast,
or go slow, that's okay,
it's not okay for an action that goes
the first half of it is fast and
then the second half is slow, where
I have to do something more serious,
some more serious dynamic
time-warping or something like that.
The whole idea is that we have these
atomic primitives, that can be performed
quickly or slowly, but
they don't have lots of parts to them.
It's very, it's,
recursive so it's very fast.
What's interesting is, and I've had
conversations with some, people who do
work in vision from the neural side, or
from, computational vision from biology.
You could imagine building
something like these mhi detectors
from very simple neural hardware.
Basically filters with slow responses.
And, the fact that these can work
from very low resolution images,
which I haven't shown, but
because it's just a global pattern
you don't need a lot of pixels.
It means that out here in your
peripheral vision where you have hardly
any resolution at all,
when we do the human vision, lesson.
We'll, we'll talk about how, you think
you can see out here, but not really.
You're just making it up.
All right, but,
what it means is a very low resolution.
You can recognize things.
So I'm not going to claim anything
in terms of biological reality.
I'll just say that there's some
biological plausibility to,
to this kind of work.
And there's a reference in PAMI,
which sort of talks more about this.
We actually use this system
to build a couple things.
Here's Jim Davis, when we were both
much younger building a aerobics system,
where you would be taken through
aerobics by the system and
it would watch you and it would know
which, which aerobic you're doing,
I mean which one you're
supposed to be doing.
It tells you, so
it can recognize it was real easy.
We did have this cool little thing that
the music in Jim is very clever making
this happen, the music was actually MIDI
controlled so we can control the tempo.
Right, it wasn't just prerecorded.
So that means we could watch you, and
we could always make the music go just
a little faster then you were going.
So we could sort of, just play with your
head and speed you up and make you sweat
more, but it was cool that the thing
would just recognize the system.
A more compelling use of this
technology, we built this thing called
the KidsRoom, and it was an interactive
play space for children.
The original intent was to
just illustrate how computer
vision could do some
interesting cool stuff.
And, what was interesting is,
nice article about it in Presence,
but, some folks came by,
I don't remember exactly how it was
that they were at the media lab.
But they really liked it and they
ported it to the Millennium Dome, so
they built this big thing
called the Millennium Dome,
in London, at the turn of the century,
at the millennium.
And they had all these pavilions,
and they were looking for
interesting technologies, and this is
one of them that they put in there.
So, I, I have a little video here
that shows you first of all,
temporal templates being used.
So the monsters teach the kids these
moves, and then, which is good,
because if we wanted to we could
actually get training data from
the actual kids that were there, but the
system is robust enough that we could
use training data from just a couple
of people that we trained on and
it would work for everybody.
We also used temporal templates plus,
this little extra stuff that we used.
It's all in the paper if you
wanted to read about it.
The, the Presence paper.
And then there was a little interesting,
cool thing in, interac.
Well here, I'll just get this started.
Okay, so here we have the last bit
where the monsters are teaching,
the last two of the moves,
there are only four of them.
First he teaches the kid to do a crouch,
and then she does a crouch in response,
and, he's praising how well she's doing
these crouches, and that's great.
We go to the point where he's teaching
her to do these flapping motions, and
you can see he's pleased with her.
And he's giving her
lots of good feedback.
And then I think the last one he's going
to teach her how to do is how to spin.
Say something like surely love
do a spin, and ready spin dude.
There he goes, he's spinning, and
now she starts spinning,
and compliment her on that.
And when the music changes,
basically they're supposed
to do their own moves and
the monsters will follow them but, it
takes them a little while to catch on.
And from now on he's following her.
Now one of the thing's that we did in
order to make this room look a lot
smarter.
The monster would say what you're doing,
right?
And when it would recognize it but
it only did that,
when it was sure it was right.
If it was close maybe you're spinning,
maybe you're flapping it would just do
whichever one it thought was right.
But it would only say
it if it were sure.
And the reason is,
if the monster goes and
does something that is not what
you are doing, what do you do?
You say, oh,
he wanted to do something else.
You just describe intentionality
to the character, but, if he says,
oh really cool spin,
and you're flapping?
He just looks stupid.
So the way you avoid this interactive
system from looking stupid,
is it only speaks when it's sure,
and it acts all the time,
because you'll ascribe intentionality.
We, we wrote that up in the paper.
It was kind of a cool insight in terms
of how to build interactive characters